foreign
[Music]
Junior
thank you
[Music]
foreign
oh my God
[Music]
um Christian
thank you
[Music]
foreign
if this is your first time thank you for
being here
all right a couple of announcements we
have senior Sunday coming up
and also let us know if you have any
High School seniors nice
um if you have a heart for kiddos
then we and are willing to serve in the
second through sixth grade classroom
please fill out a card on the tiny
little table in the hallway
and give us your name and number and
right kids table in the comments section
our vision and goal is to have enough
volunteers to allow for once every three
weeks rotation
and now I'm going to hand it over to
Kelly
who is going to invite us into worship
okay thanks
happy Mother's Day and in honor of
Mother's Day I wore my coaching uniform
yeah
I meant to change and then here we are
so this is Mother's Day yes sometimes I
look cuter than this so
happy Mother's Day
a day that is set aside for adoration
and celebration of motherhood as it
should be however I know this day isn't
that for some people we recognize that
and it would be far from the values of
the table to not that being said I
wanted to share a perspective of
Mother's Day that really touched me this
perspective has melted my heart and
honestly brought me from the shores of
Christianity to the deeps of it soaking
in the love of God God as mother
I wanted to share a poem written by
Amanda Woodward it's so fitting for the
moms in the room that are in the throes
of it and it's fitting for the moms that
ache on Mother's Day May the perspective
of God as mother
give you hope
rest and perhaps draw you to the deeps
as well
I'm going to read this poem and if you
want to close your eyes and just
Envision the most loving
vision of someone holding you in their
Embrace god mother a motherly figure
um
just I invite you to picture that
to be a mother is to suffer to travail
in the dark stretched and torn exposed
in half-naked humiliation subjected to
indignities for the sake of New Life
to be a mother is to say this is my body
broken for you and in the next instance
in response to the created's Primal
hunger this is my body Take and Eat to
be a mother is to self-empty to neither
slumber nor sleep so attuned you are to
cries in the night offering the comfort
of yourself and the assurances of I'm
here
to be a mother is to weep over the
fighting and exclusions in wounds your
children inflict on one another to long
for reconciliation and Brotherly Love
sisterly love and when all is said and
done to gather all parties the offender
and the offended into the folds of your
Embrace and to whisper in their ears
that they are beloved
to be a mother is to be vulnerable to be
misunderstood railed against blamed for
the heartaches of the billwildered
children who don't know where else to
cast the inks they feel over their own
existing existence in this perplexing
Universe to be a mother is to hoist onto
your hips Those whom your image is
imprinted bearing the burden of their
weight rejoicing in their returned
affection delighting in their Wonder
bleeding in the presence of their pain
to be a mother is to be accused of
sentimentality one moment and Injustice
the next to be the receiver of endless
demands absorber of Perpetual complaints
reckoner of bottomless needs to be a
mother is to be an artist a keeper of
memories past Weaver of stories Untold
Visionary of lives looming ahead
to be a mother is to be the first voice
listened to and the first disregarded
to be a mender of broken creations and
comforter of the distraught children
whose hands rot them to be a mother is
to be a touchstone and the source the
stower of names
influencer of identities life Giver
life shaper
empath healer and the original love
would you guys stand with us as we enter
into worship together
[Music]
yeah let's just together if we can
imagine As we sing out this first course
it's just the word amen which means may
it be so
and as we sing that together I wonder if
we could just kind of Envision in our
minds whatever experience we've had up
to this point
with either our own mother
or our desire to be a mother or our
experience of being a mother whether all
the pain all the joy all the in-betweens
I just went to us to Envision As we sing
this chorus and lift it up that our best
picture
of motherhood is in the God who is love
that original love that Kelly just named
and can we just agree on that together
and sing amen and lift that up in unity
[Music]
one two three four
amen
[Music]
amen let's sing it again
amen
amen last time lift your voices
hope falling down like big love that I
can't explain peace that steals my soul
life
the darkest Place alive
[Applause]
coming home
[Music]
you I'm alive again
praise God
foreign
[Music]
Spirit of the voice
there is
[Music]
may God Almighty my every year
take are in the past
[Music]
ing it out where the spirit of the Lord
is
there is freedom
I am free amen
where the spirit of the Lord is there is
freedom
I am free amen we see where the spirit
of the Lord is
there is
[Music]
there is freedom
I am free amen
[Music]
God is so good
she's so good too
[Music]
she cares for me
she's so good too
me
she loves me so
[Music]
she
loves me so
she's so good
to me
God is so good
[Music]
God is
so good
she's so good too
[Music]
we want to go ahead and dismiss the kids
to go to their classrooms thank you guys
for singing with us for those first
couple songs and thank you kids ministry
workers who are serving our kids and
loving on them so well we really
appreciate you guys
chill
[Music]
Angie Devin
other people that I'm forgetting
[Music]
I wanted to take just a moment
to read some
or Isaiah sorry
[Music]
it says Zion said the Lord has forsaken
me the Lord has forgotten me
but can a mother forget the baby at her
breast and have no compassion on the
child she's born
even though she may forget
I will not forget you
see I have engraved you on the palms of
my hands
your walls are ever before me
[Music]
thank you
I lose my abilities
[Music]
foreign
thank you
you've got this away
chasing away those
Shadows hang around
again
[Music]
finding out just who I am
stability
to be afraid when I hear you say my name
[Music]
to my head
and they are gone when you speak
and I
feel
your faith everything changes
your smile
[Music]
got this way up
Shadows to hang around
[Music]
but I fall down again
I'm finding out just to I am
fall down again
I'm finding out just who I am
[Music]
Feeling Good by sharing and goodbye
homelessness and pain
I have heard the father
Call My Name a goodbye running goodbye
[Music]
have no mercy hello peace
and everything changes
[Music]
your face
Everything Changes
[Music]
we got this way up
Shadows that hang around
and Lord I fall down again
[Music]
I'm finding out just who I am sing that
one more time Lord I fall down
again
I'm finding out just who I am
hello joy and hello true hello
[Music]
for all this moments
foreign
[Music]
God is so good
God is so good she's so good too
[Music]
God tonight
would we connect with the part of your
heart that gathers us as children under
your wings
please
would we connect with a God who makes
room for us at the table and always
saves the space
who doesn't forget us or forsake us or
abandon us but seeks us out like a
Shepherd going after the one sheep
God would we connect with a part of your
heart that calls us home that calls us
back to return to ourselves to original
love
[Music]
to original creation
you are our creator
you have done a good thing and you will
continue to do a good work in US
Jesus we connect with your heart tonight
and not only as individuals but as a
community that comes together and
desires to make that space for each
other to make that room for one another
to call each other back home
to save a seat
for the broken and the Forgotten and the
abandoned
for the lost and the vulnerable and the
marginalized
[Music]
do we make that space
Jesus thank you for the way that you've
loved us
thank you for the way that you seek us
out
and call us back to ourselves back to
your heart
[Music]
God would we meet you powerfully tonight
there
[Music]
in Jesus name
amen
thank you guys
go ahead and turn to the people around
you say hello welcome them if you
haven't met them before get to know them
a little and then Brett will get us
started on our message
thank you
well Grace and peace it is really really
good to be with you and my name is Brett
and the pastor here and
um I just want to extend a warm welcome
that includes of course all of you but
as always those joining us online love
you a lot you're not forgotten and
um also anyone here who is new thank you
so much for being with us I know uh you
know depending on Church backgrounds and
stories and such even just entering into
a building like this again you know can
be like oh gosh deep breaths and so
um all that to say I'm just I'm really
grateful that um that you're here so
thank you and uh you have come on a good
Sunday because we are kind of nearing
the end of our Easter tide series and
um you know I'm excited for every
message but this one's just near and
dear to my heart I just you know
sometimes I don't even uh I mean mostly
I'm I don't get up here without being at
least reasonably happy with what I'm
gonna say you know I mean like granted
you can't go for every week you just you
know every week you're not always like
over the moon you know but this is one
that I wrote and I was like oh my gosh
well thanks God I really like this you
know so
um it was good so uh I'll be hilarious
and you're like that was one of those
you know I mean you're all in the car
driving home
um so yeah don't tell me if if you hate
it don't say that just be like good good
sermon Pastor you know I mean that's
what that's what I know it was bad
they're like good service
a certain look
um so we are in a series titled Easter
tide
um this is not the end and I know for
many of us you know we grew up um
perhaps in in church and Easter was like
one day thing and so what we're trying
to do in this series is
um kind of balance out the season of
lint which is you know 40 days of kind
of spiritual preparation and many of us
like fasted something and kind of
leading up to the day of the Cross and
then of course Easter Sunday is like oh
one day all right well
move on and so we're kind of trying to
bring some balance and do like you know
good six seven weeks um just celebrating
Easter and looking at some of the kind
of post after Resurrection
um stories uh from Christ and uh so
we're just yeah that's kind of what this
is about and realizing you know Easter
is not just about hooray for Jesus but
it's really an invitation
um for all of us to begin uh following
the resurrected Jesus so with that in
mind the title of my message this week
is drawn drawn and our passage is from
John 14.
verses 15 through 19. and it says this
this is Christ speaking he says if you
love me
keep my commands
and I will ask the father
and he will give you another Advocate to
help you and be with you forever the
spirit of Truth
it was um when we were kind of
worshiping I noticed up there in the
cross you can see the dove symbolizing
the spirit of God you know who comes
from the source god father mother as we
sang right because it's it's all um it's
it's poetic it's metaphor trying to say
God the source we're God's children you
know I mean so we kind of get often hung
up on like the gender uh when it's of
course it's it's poetic
um
yeah so he says I'm going to send you
um another Advocate to healthy to be
with you forever the spirit of Truth
the world cannot accept him because it
either sees him nor knows him but you
know him for he lives with you and will
be in you
I will not leave you as orphans
it's a good word you know we're not
orphans sometimes we feel abandoned by
God uh but it's just not the case we're
not I will not leave you as orphans I
will come to you
before long the world will not seem
anymore but you will see me because I
live you also will live
so where I want to focus in this message
is actually just on that opening verse
just verse 15. there's plenty of sermons
and all this but I it was really verse
15 that um that caught me which simply
says if you love me
um keep my commands
and you know this really kind of begs I
think a few questions first that came to
mind would be like uh which commands you
know sort of like uh which ones you have
in mind now what's interesting if you if
we were to keep reading like the chapter
and even what came before after he
doesn't really get into it like okay so
here's the commands you know point one a
one B one C point two a you know it
doesn't really do like um yeah it
doesn't really give it here it's I think
it's sort of assumed it's um you know
everything he's been talking about his
whole life and message if you've ever um
read uh like Matthew Mark Luke John the
four kind of main gospels the four main
stories of Christ
um he does you know quite a bit of
teaching and uh probably the most
condensed section of teaching would be
like from the sermon on the mountain in
Matthew chapters five six and seven and
there's many commands there there's like
um ones about uh you know do not hate
uh don't hate your brother don't hate
your sister
don't lust don't don't retaliate in a
spirit of Vengeance and even further
says love your enemies that's a hard one
I heard uh there's a bit of an uproar in
kids ministry last week when they were
teaching the kids about love your
enemies and gosh darn it they just
couldn't accept that you know like what
is this crazy teaching you know
um it is a tough one you know we just
and it's it's interesting how we can
kind of just receive it like oh yeah
yeah I love you and you know I mean yeah
that's a good word you know we don't
throw pitch a fit when the pastor says
that we just sort of Nod and move on you
know
um so that's this God gives us pause
to kind of come back to like oh okay
this is uncomfortable
I love your enemies give to the needy
he says when you pray assuming we'll
pray when you fast assuming well fast uh
don't be anxious
that's the whole famous section about
the birds you look at the birds of the
air you know they don't toil and spin
and freak out every day like oh my gosh
where I'm gonna eat next you know
they're just like doing their thing
doesn't God take care of them won't he
take care of you you know and so
and do not judge so and I can keep going
you know I mean we could be here all
night and weekend whatever
um
so if in essence you know I wouldn't get
too lost in like the mystery of what is
he talking about the commands it's all a
lot of it if you've kind of been in the
context of church for a while like you
start to pick up on some of the values
you know I mean a really good command be
like love you know loving each other
that would be a great foundational you
know thing so often I think more often
than not we kind of know the good you
know I mean we know roughly where we're
headed what we should do
um
and uh so which kind of leads to
question number two right if you love me
keep
the commands
um and I do think you know in the church
we pretty clearly have a crisis I don't
just means the table even the broader
Church like a crisis of keeping
um even in my own life you know a crisis
of like
actually keeping the commands Mindy um
referenced last week when she was
leading worship a uh a wonderful passage
from Romans chapter 7 where Paul
describes um the very things I
um want to do that's what I don't do and
then all the things I'm like oh I hate
that that's the worst I always regret it
that's what I keep doing over and over
and over you know and he's naming that
crisis of of keeping you know and it is
like it's a real um it's a real
challenge you know so if you're kind of
feeling like I'm oh I'm talking right to
you well don't worry I'm talking right
to all of us we're all kind of there in
the crisis of you know of the keeping
and um
you know I think if I were to
um kind of preach this message back
15 years ago in uh in my youth pastor
days youth pastor Brett
I think I think where I would have gone
from here
um is in essence to really double down
on the keeping
in the emphasis there in in essence
um I might have like preached a little
sermon though I would have stretched it
out to 30 minutes somehow
uh pastors are good at that reachers are
good now you could have said that in
five minutes yeah well you know
um I think it would have gone something
like a little something like this like
uh Church in essence you know we say we
we say we love God you know love the
Lord
um and it's amazing how easily
statements of love for God just sort of
roll you know right out of our mouths
like oh do you love the Lord oh I love
the Lord love Jesus you know
um and yet we we don't do what he
commands like where's the disconnect
like what are we what are we missing
here uh it it just feels to me like
again this is what I would have preached
don't worry
um it feels to me
like we need to
um begin to like strive to obey long to
obey like to to push ourselves further
and like harder than we've pushed in the
past
because clearly like whatever effort
we've been giving it as the church like
it's just not thinking getting it done
youth pastor Brett was you know a little
a little intense there
um
but but maybe you I don't know maybe
there's a part of you that kind of
resonates you know what I mean like
there's and maybe there's a party that's
sort of like oh that sounds like the
worst you know you know um probably
different people you know in different
places
and um
I I think it's it's interesting
um there was one of the great I'd say
like great souls in the Christian
tradition in the last hundred years
um is named or was named he just passed
away a few years ago his name was Dallas
Willard a few of you may be familiar
with his work is really good good soul
and
um I was reading some of his thoughts on
this exact passage John 14 15.
and it was interesting that he gave the
exact opposite interpretation
and of what I just gave and I realize
now after I've journeyed you know 15
years
um you know I'm not really youth pastor
Brett anymore
and even though I think discipline and
it has this place
that's its place in life you can't like
totally get away from it you know
um
but in essence I really agree with where
Willard takes it and and what he
basically
um points out he says you know we the
way we read this passage and maybe even
the way it hit you I'd be curious you
know how it hit you initially like if
you love me keep my commands
says we often hear that in a very human
way
um
almost a um
prove that you love me
because I don't believe you
you know and this is it's a very like
human way of reading it where we even do
this sometimes with each other like if
you love me
you will
fill in the blank you know what I mean
if you if you really loved me
um I mean I'm just imagining like if
this if we started to not started some
of us kind of do operate this way in our
relationships not for the better
you know like it gets kind of
manipulative because it's almost like
yeah it's almost like you kind of do
know they love you but you know you can
get more out of them
you know I mean if you kind of kind of
project as though I really don't I don't
know I don't know I don't know if you I
don't know if you love me you know
I like and just you can see where this
starts to get into
um the ways we relate with one another
and it's like kind of the Shadow side of
it like I'm imagining if I started to
relate to my kids more and more in this
way
be bad you know like hey if you love me
you get straight A's
you know like that you can see the the
kind of all of you you had a collective
you know it is it's kind of gross like
um or the reverse if they're like well
Dad you know if you loved me
you'd get me those new shoes I want you
know it's like
what kind of a relationship is this you
know you can feel the weirdness of
um of that so Willard names is um that's
he says I don't think this is where
Jesus is coming from I don't think he's
like if you really love me you'll keep
the commands and then I'll know you know
um he says no instead
um what if instead of kind of
emphasizing the keeping kind of like I
did in my little previous sermonette
there you know from 15 years ago
emphasizing the keeping doubling down
like you know I'm asking if you double
down triple down quadruple down then the
Love Will Follow then we'll know that
you love you know what if Willard says
what if you reverse it
and the way he he kind of summarizes it
he says what if the source of the
keeping
is what
the loving
and when I read that it was one of those
things that I kind of intuitively was
like feeling out and kind of knowing
when I when I read those words I just
thought gosh darn it Dallas Willard that
is beautiful that's it
the source of the keeping is the loving
um what does he he mean in essence
um he's pointing out that it's a
renovated Heart of Love
it's an it's a inner transformation and
healing you might even say that then
manifests outwardly in such beautiful
ways the way he kind of summarized it he
said um keeping the commands of Jesus is
either easy or impossible
that's the way he put it
it's easy or it's impossible now what
does he mean
um
he even speak to yourself think of this
like in your own life maybe there are
certain commands or certain things like
that you do find kind of easy or like
because
um God's done something in your own
heart and mind
right and there's like a certain way of
being that it's just who you are I don't
know you don't even like think about it
a lot and maybe even people say like I
think that's so admirable of you you
know manager is sort of like oh okay you
know but it's not like you're not
sitting there every day white knuckling
it like oh I just gotta you know
um
like you know in essence there's things
that it flows from the inside
um to the outside and uh the way I might
kind of put in my own words is to say
it's true it's true that the church has
a crisis of obedience to the teachings
of Jesus and I don't want to minimize
that however the answer I think is not a
greater striving
um it's got to be a greater loving
it's got to be a renovation of the heart
and mind towards God because you can see
where
churches really wrestle with this
and often I think it's sort of two paths
to uh I said Robert Frost two roads
Divergent wood you know it's sort of
like you gotta kind of as a church
Community you end up having to choose
your path
um in a way of what will you emphasize
more you know I mean like both of these
are at play the keeping the loving but
like which one are you really gonna
Double Down triple down you know say
like this is the solution this is the
you know this is the answer like like
which one
um which one will it you know will it be
and um
in essence you can think like one is the
key is the keeping the obedience route
and the other is the the loving route
and you can see where churches I think
that opt for the kind of you know Pastor
Brother 15 years ago double down it ends
up um
becoming a kind of forcing pushing right
you might say obedience forces
fear like pushes
um but it's ultimately it's love what
does love do it calls
and it draws us
and before we know it
suddenly the keeping begins to happen
have you ever had this kind of a little
bit of this this experience like where
the keeping it's sort of I mean thinking
coming back to the parenting analogy
forgive me if I do too many of those I'm
just in that season of life
um but there's uh I'm thinking of like
you know like a like a parent who like
just can't get their darn kids to ever
obey like at all you know what I mean
but you can tell there's like a certain
harshness and uh like they've gotten
into this combative kind of cycle and
it's just haywire and and maybe like a
lot some love is lacking you know and
then someone else kind of comes in and
there's like a certain like okay I still
got to set the boundaries but hey I love
you like you're loved
and like all of a sudden
that kid like I'm thinking specifically
kind of coming out of like abuse or
something you know
um and it's like whoa that kid is like
starting to slowly but surely I mean I'm
not saying they're like they're an angel
overnight you know
um but it's like all of a sudden there's
what's happening
responding called and drawn by love
um there's a marvelous quote from the
French writer Antoine I'd look it up on
YouTube because I don't know French
Antoine dusson
that's how I got on YouTube said it so I
just practiced it a lot this week for
y'all
foreign
is a tragedy
um and so he's he's a writer and so he
um he said like this if you want to
build a ship
Don't drum up people to collect wood and
don't assign them tasks and work but
rather teach them to long for the
endless immensity of the sea
oh I love that now I think it's poetry
right so I don't think in a you can take
this overly literally there's no reason
for tasks in this world throw away your
to-do list no need you know I mean like
well actually okay
if you really want to build a ship like
probably you do need some tasks and you
know but you can see the deeper truth
he's getting at right because you can
imagine people who don't want anything
to do with building a ship and it's like
well gosh darn I can't I'm getting all
the to-do's and everything's planned out
and their motivation levels are low but
all of a sudden if they want to
if they long to
oh now all they need is like a little
guidance and they're off and running
like to kind of translate this into our
kind of time today
um we might say it like this if you
um want people to keep Jesus commands
don't guilt-trip them about their sins
and don't scare them with threats of
hell don't force them into church
attendance though all those can kind of
work in a way in this especially in the
short run but rather teach them to long
for the immensity of the God who is love
amen
like like when we start to get that
figured out
then suddenly
things start taking off
and you might reverse it and say until
we get that figured out
were just like gears grinding I gotta
gotta discipline myself
gotta make myself pray I really
ought to do such and such I really I
should I should be in church again I
know I should I really should you know I
mean you can just hear the gears
grinding
as opposed to
learning to long for God
from this vantage point I think
discipleship and what churches are doing
and what we're doing at the table
suddenly starts to click into Focus
it's interesting that Jesus didn't say
go ye therefore and make converts of the
whole world
he said go and make disciples and and
what is
discipleship I think it's more than just
belief or like get everyone on the same
page theologically
get them all to believe the same things
about Jesus and about God about the
church and you know what I mean about
the resurrection once we believe problem
solved everything Clicks in place like
[Music]
it's discipleship you might say it's
really about
um desire
discipleship is a question of what has
captured your heart
church what do you long for
what do you love
what vision of the good life are you
chasing
that's your God
that's your religion
like you can see where on the one hand
it's sort of beautiful good news of like
oh all I have to do is learn to love God
and things will start clicking into
place you know and like that is the good
news the challenging news is that our
hearts are captured by so many different
kind of competing visions of like what
to love and long for and you know living
in the society and the culture we do
like it's everywhere I mean just think
of marketing and advertising
what is that it's teaching you to long
for the immensity of the
fill in the blank
you know what I mean the immensity of
the Porsche you know or like I see these
YouTube videos that um and I click them
off when my sons fall into them they're
11 and 8 and so they love these YouTube
videos where the guys like you know like
around maybe 1819 super high energy and
he's like hey watch me as I'm driving
around the Bay Area in my rented
Lamborghini you know and I'm watching
this I'm just like oh my gosh this is so
stupid but my boys right are just like
yes oh
these guys are awesome dad come
it's a neon green Lamborghini you know
and I'm like
exit like nope
um okay I'm not that quiet I'm kind of
like yeah that's cool but guys can you
see what's going and I tried to explain
and then click off because what's that
what's what's happening there that is
it's discipleship
in essence right it's teaching them what
to long for
what to desire
and you can see though where this gets
like real sideways you know in our
culture and every week I drive by them
there's so many examples of this and of
course it's different for every person
like this question what do you love what
do you long for what's driving you and
it even shifts from season to season you
know like I mean there's a season where
you're like oh I'm starting to really
hunger for God and there's like
something happening inside me and it's
like so good and then all of a sudden
like distraction you know I mean just
pulled off like oh no it's this you know
like I don't and it's crazy I mean I'm
just thinking in my own life and I'm
like all over the place at times like
this is the new vision of the you know
this is in essence it's like being saved
you know like that's gonna be my
salvation
then I'll be happy you know
um every week I have my my side gig and
uh and some of y'all know what I do
um and I and well now I have to say it
so I pick up dog poop is my side gig
um it tastes pretty good though at least
you know it's pretty good and so um so
every every week my route takes me right
down Allen um off exchange near the
waters Creek area beautiful homes and
like I mean amazing you know that's
right but there's this one marketing
sign that I mean every time I drive by I
look at it and I kind of think of these
themes because it's just this picture of
this like deliriously happy couple and
they're just you assume they're looking
at because this advertisement for a home
you know so the home's not there because
it's their faith you know and I mean
they're just over the top like
and it just says this is this you've
earned it
you've earned it
like can you hear where people people
will work 20 30 40 50 60 years like to
get to that neighborhood you know what I
mean like that's my vision that that's
my vision of the good life that's the
thing
right now am I saying like if you own a
home that's thin you know like no this
is right this is where it's a we've got
to do a heart check you know what I mean
and kind of say like hmm what's my Pro
what's going on in here what Vision am I
and you know am I pursuing and then
allow God to rightly order
um our desires
there's a number another or there's a
quote from James K Smith who writes
really eloquently on all this if you
want more on these topics you can read
the book you are um you are what you
love
and uh he says this we aren't really
motivated by abstract ideas or pushed by
rules and duties
instead some panoramic Tableau that
means like Vision picture
um of what looks like flourishing has an
alluring power that attracts
that's uh you good you're good
did it go out
sweet all right there we go check check
test test am I good not yet
it's green so
y'all can hear me so we'll go all right
cool
um
so this oh I just this I mean you can
hear a lot of the message in this I mean
you can hear John 14 15 in that
you know what I mean like in essence do
you what are we going to do we're going
to double down triple down on The
Obedience thing and like every all you
all need to enter Christian boot camp
and you know get disciplined you know
you know we're gonna do that play that
game or are we gonna do a different game
are we gonna go a different route and
and I think what he's really arguing for
here is um as human beings ultimately
we're Desiring creatures
and so better to play this game better
to ask constantly ask ourselves hmm what
do I love what do I love what do I love
what's what's calling me what's drawing
me and you can hear too where it's sort
of a matter of like a hierarchy like you
know we what's at the top that's really
the question you know because there's we
have other desires and I don't know I'd
like a a good family and I want to be
you know like there's all sorts of
desires you know those are fine you know
I'm not saying like loving God's the
only desire you should have none other
you know like no it's a matter of like
what's at the top of that hierarchy that
scene that's really the question
um
so
kind of in closing I think what I want
to talk about is this um you know what
does it mean to grow in our love for for
Christ and in essence if you've been
here at all for this series I mean it's
everything we've been talking about when
I think of like what's the Christian
vision of flourishing
um I think it's really nothing less than
Union
and deepest connection with the God who
is love
like at its heart that's that's kind of
the vision it's nothing less than Union
and deepest connection with the God who
is love
and I think when the Way Saint Augustine
put it is um our hearts are restless
until they rest in you
that's a that's a that's worth chewing
on this week
you know because we find ourselves
restless and like what do we need hmm
God how do I rest In You In This Moment
there's a beautiful quote I'll finish
with this one this is from uh brother
Liam Strahan he was a monk this is from
a documentary titled Brotherhood the
inner life of monks and he's right at
the very end of his life actually like
close to like death bed and um this is
what what he said I think it's see if
you can kind of catch an ear for the
vision of the good life from a very
Christian christ-centered way he says
this I've been 60 years before in a
monastery
in the early days my prayer was
something that we did
now I don't pray
ER is the atmosphere in which I live
my whole life is just a prayer to God
do you understand I don't say prayers
the presence of God is something that
I'm aware of all the time I'm just
living in the presence of God that's my
prayer
and friends that's the vision of
Christian flourishing
and if we start to catch kind of a taste
for God so to speak
um
heart for God then I think you'll find
that the keeping the keeping will follow
so
as we come to the table of the Lord
tonight
as we take in the body of Christ in the
breath the blood of Christ
in the wine may this be kind of a moment
where we can do a little bit of that
heart check
you know I kind of trust that that
perhaps even as I've been speaking God's
been speaking to you
you know like what's going on in that
Restless Heart
what's going on in there what kind of
desires
um need to be kind of curated and
de-centered so that A Love For The God
Who is love
um father-son Spirit can take Center
Stage again and so I encourage you as we
come forward to take in the body of
Christ and the bread the blood of Christ
and the wine may it be that kind of
re-centering moment for you so the way
we're going to do this is we'll start
just with kind of the front rows and
we'll just work our way back we've
practiced what's called an Open Table I
mean if you're here tonight and you want
to participate uh then you are free to
do that there's something in your heart
that's like hey I don't know if I have
like all the right theology or the right
Faith or ideas or whatever but I want to
connect with the Risen Jesus whatever
mysterious way that happens then you are
you're free to participate the red cups
are wine the white cups are grape juice
and finally you can just go ahead and
partake any time uh immediately you can
return to your seat and partake No One's
Gonna like lead you through the exact
you know taking of the of the elements
so this is the table
not of the church
but of the Lord
and it's made ready for those who love
him and for those who want to love him
more
so come
you who have much faith and you who have
little
you who have been here often and you who
have not been here long
you who have tried to follow in you who
have failed
because it's the Lord Jesus
himself who invites you
it's the Lord Jesus who invites you and
it's his will that those who want to
meet him should meet him here
come to the table
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
keeping with our theme our worship theme
tonight as kind of God our mother
this closing song is a song by Josh
garrels Josh garrels Josh somebody
um it's called at the table I love the
words of this song Just because it kind
of recommunicates that idea of
regardless of where we go where we stray
what paths we take
There Is Our God calling us back home
calling us to return to ourselves
holding that space for us so you guys
are welcome to remain seated if you'd
like for this first for this last song
and just let those words sink into your
heart they'll be up on the screen there
are a lot of words in this song so it
can be a little tricky to sing along to
so feel free to just let it sink in and
I hope that each of us kind of sense
that
um that call back home to to The God Who
Loved Us who created us
gonna get a Tempo going in here so Gary
has something to follow
[Music]
the troubles
not a million ranking five but got where
I came from the summer back when I was
young I was a good man's child
[Music]
I lost some nameless things my innocence
flew away from me she had a hide a face
in my desire to embrace forbidden five
but at night I dream she's singing over
me
oh oh my child
come on home
[Music]
to me
and I will hold you in my arms and
joyful beings
always
[Music]
be a place for you at my table
turn to me
[Music]
wondering where I might begin
Sun there ain't nothing you can do
listen close and follow me I'll take you
where you're meant to be
[Music]
safe
slept with my head I fall asleep
my mother runs with me
[Music]
home to me
and I will hold you in my arms
[Music]
come on home
home
home to me
and I will hold you in my arms and
joyful beings
[Music]
return
to me
[Music]
wow what a worship team huh that's great
listen I wanted to thank you so much for
joining us this evening
and if you're new we would really like
for you to fill out a card on the tiny
little table on the way out the door
and let us know your information it will
allow us to follow up with you and we'll
be able to answer any questions that you
might have
and also we want to say thank you for
visiting with us today
my name is Janine and if you need any
kind of a prayer a hug or any just
general support find me after the
service and I would love to be there for
you however I can
here at the table we are committed to
creating an inclusive community that
touches the lives and supports other
like-minded non-profits we believe that
generosity is a key component of
building the kind of community that we
envision and we are so grateful for
those who have already partnered with us
in this endeavor
for those who are considering joining us
in this Mission you can do that online
at
thetabletexas.org or at the box at the
small table in the hallway
remember that senior Sunday is coming up
on June 4th
we want to be sure that if you have a
high school senior that you'd like to
recognize that you'll fill out a card at
the table and let us know
[Music]
and now it's really my pleasure to send
you out in your week with this blessing
[Music]
you are a child of God
you are you are a child of God this is
true on your best day
and it's true on your worst day
so as you go into your week
ahead with its yet to be determined
highs and lows and everything in between
go
filled with the assurance that you are
loved
you are worthy and you are accepted Just
As You Are
and go filled with God's holy spirit
and the desire to extend these same
Gifts of Grace and unconditional love to
everyone you come in contact with
be blessed and have a good week we hope
to see you here next Sunday
[Music]
foreign
always
be your place
[Music]